foreign
[Music]
the year is
1656. your body is racked by violent
chills your head pounds your muscles are
too weak to sit up and you feel like
rancid hard-boiled eggs are squeezing
out of your neck and armpits
in your feverish State you see a strange
looking man approach his face obscured
by a beak-like mask his body covered
from head to toe he examines you and
even without seeing his face you know
the diagnosis you have the plague the
plague stands out as one of the most
terrifying and destructive diseases in
human history it swept across large
parts of afro-eurasia in three separate
pandemics starting in the 6th 14th and
19th centuries killed tens of millions
of people and had in the best of cases
about a 40 survival rate
the European plague doctor with his
beaked mask and wizard-like robes is one
of the image's most popularly associated
with plague today he's often found in
books and films about The 14th Century
pandemic known as the Black Death
the only problem is that's about as
accurate as placing a modern surgeon at
the court of Louis XIV in Versailles the
confusion is understandable though the
Black Death had several aftershocks
including a series of devastating
outbreaks in Western Europe during the
17th century this is when the iconic
plague doctor actually emerged on the
scene
first described in the early 17th
century the outfit consisted of a hood
with Crystal eyepieces and a beak filled
with a pungent combination of herbs and
compounds this could include cinnamon
pepper turpentine roast copper and
powdered Viper flesh this recipe was
inspired by the famed second century
Greco-Roman physician Galen and was
thought to ward off poisoned air known
as miasma
people believed this bad air spread
plague after emanating from swamps and
sources of Decay such as dead plants or
animal carcasses
in earlier centuries doctors across
Europe carried metal palmanders filled
with similar mixtures and it's possible
that the beak evolved as a hands-free
alternative
the rest of the costume which included
an oiled leather robe boots and gloves
acted as kind of an early hazmat suit
likely designed to block miasma from
entering through the Skin's pores while
this shows some basic understanding that
plague spread from one place to another
these doctors couldn't know that in most
cases the true culprit was a tiny flea
transmitting the bacteria yersinia
pestis from one person or animal to
another it's possible that the plague
doctor's outfit may have provided some
unintentional protection from flea bites
however not enough information survives
to know whether the costumed doctors
fared any better than their ordinarily
robed counterparts
it's no surprise that this bizarre get
up has captured popular imagination
despite the fact that its use was
limited to a few places in Italy and
France during the 17th and early 18th
centuries
even at the time it was viewed with
Macabre Fascination and occasionally
used to mock the ineffective and Corrupt
Practices of some Physicians
[Music]
until the 20th century there was no
effective treatment for the plague but
that didn't stop doctors costumed or not
from trying they consulted the works of
earlier Physicians for guidance did what
they could defend off miasma and
prescribed a variety of concoctions and
antidotes they also relied on pre-modern
medical Mainstays these could include
bloodletting which involved draining
sometimes concerningly large amounts of
blood in an attempt to remove poison or
restore the body's Natural Balance or
cupping where the rim of a heated glass
was placed over swollen lymph nodes in
hopes of making them burst sooner a sign
when it occurred naturally that a plague
patient was on the mend or perhaps most
painfully cautery which involved Lancing
the lymph nodes with a red-hot poker to
release the blackened pus Within
a lot has changed since their times
modern medicine has given us the means
to quickly identify bacterial as well as
viral threats and to effectively
mobilize against them we also have
access to Technologies like test kits
masks to deter the spread of respiratory
viruses and vaccines and we conduct
robust trials to make sure they're safe
and effective but some things don't
change we still depend on the courage
and compassion of medical professionals
who voluntarily risk their lives against
an invisible attacker to help and
comfort those who need it most
while a massive plague outbreak is
unlikely at this point Humanity will
likely face more Global pandemics find
out the statistical likelihood of
another pandemic occurring in your
lifetime plus some ways we might prevent
or minimize any future pandemics with
this video
[Music]